Jason is in Chicago hi Jason
welcome to the show hey thank you
sure what's up so I'm 24 years old in
August I'm starting my master's program
in September I've already got about
$50,000 in undergrad debt from all over
the place and then this next program
it's going to cost about $72,000 a year
what do you guess person that's 72
thousand dollars a year it's a degree in
American Family Therapy from
Northwestern University go get it
somewhere else I don't know I this is
just kind of the way that the doors have
opened and to be honest with you this is
just kind of how yeah you're over if
you're if you're if you've got the cash
laying around that's fine but you're
describing me somebody's broke that's
over paying 3x for this master's degree
yeah it was after school you know the
median salary for a position like this
at least in Chicagoland area is
somewhere between 65 and 85 thousand
starting salaries which does not justify
seventy five thousand dollars for a
master's degree per year did you say
fifty thousand for a master's degree in
marriage and marriage therapy this
should be costing you no more than forty
or fifty grand
sorry Northwestern no sale no sale so
deciding let's say deciding to go to
Northwestern and finish the degree there
with the student loans and everything
while I'm in school I have like I don't
know about ten thousand left on my car
and then like six thousand of credit
card debt which I'm kind of knocking out
this the rest of this summer I did just
recently get into an injury I got hit by
a car while I was skateboarding and my
lawyer told me that I could get
somewhere between like five and twenty
five thousand dollars and with that
chunk of money I was wondering if I
should just throw that on top of some
ice all my
student loans or find a way of like
investing that money I'm not really sure
what I should do with that
okay well you should use it to pay cash
for a marriage and Family Therapy degree
at another university you cannot afford
this one more time
mathematics works like this okay a
sixteenth of an $80,000 your job is not
justified by spending a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for a degree a
master's degree that you could get for
thirty or forty somewhere else it's not
logical it's very illogical I'm being
nice I'm trying not to say it's stupid I
know don't do it man
don't do it please don't do that to
yourself
there's no that this is how people get
into student loan debt that's untenable
this discussion right here you read
about people like you in the newspaper
when we read these ridiculous situations
see you have right in front of you the
opportunity to do this and actually pay
cash for your master's degree and not do
any more harm to yourself you have a ten
thousand dollar car debt $50,000 on
undergrad you're gonna add a hundred and
fifty all to get a job that pays sixty
to eighty thousand dollars I want you to
be a marriage and family therapist I
just don't want you to overpay for the
opportunity now if you told me you had a
free ride to Northwestern or you told me
your grandpa left you two hundred
thousand dollars and this is how you
want to spend that cash I'm not gonna
argue with you so much I still think
it's probably a bad return on investment
but you're going into debt a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for a degree that
should cost you thirty or forty thousand
dollars dude that's ludicrous please
don't do it
see this is why we should end the
federally insured student loan program
right here this is why Congress should
stop harming the American people I think
we can all safely say out loud that the
student loan program is an epic failure
it's an epic failure it has caused
people to go deeply into debt to get
degrees that they overpay for or to get
the useless degrees in some cases go
deeply into debt to get degrees that are
actually worth what they paid for them
and actually good degrees that are
usable in the marketplace education is
not the great evil here universities are
not the great evil but let me tell you
what will happen to the cost of college
if we stop the federally insured student
loan program this flood of federal money
that these universities are more than
happy to spend would go away and when
the supply of money goes away do you
know what happens in economics to the
price it goes down because no one is
buying anything at the high price the
only reason these prices have gone up is
they have the money if suddenly no one
was willing to pay that to go to school
there they would these countries
universities would start using their
endowments they've got billions of
dollars they're sitting on and they can
send anybody through the school they
want to send and they just keep building
their endowments over and over and over
again but when the federal government
has when you and I you and I are the
taxpayer is ensuring that that young man
who's not doing math well we're ensuring
his loan against default you and I just
made that guy a hundred and fifty
thousand dollar loan if I didn't talk
him out of that this has got to stop
y'all you know Elizabeth Warren's
talking about Bernie's Tom Bakk
forgiving student loans that's great how
you gonna forgive student loans when you
keep making them youtubers first thing
you got to stop making the loans then we
start talking about getting out but you
politicians with your head fakes
you know we're article in The Wall
Street Journal last week just destroying
the whole student loan myth
and the lady that actually that was the
risin risin I think was her name was the
mother of the student loan program she
was in the Johnson administration when
it was formed they interviewed her
before she passed away last year and she
said the student loan program is an
absolute disaster it's a monster that's
out of control and so Congress you need
to stop this you need to stop it this is
ridiculous
well it helps you those poor people go
to college now listen tell you poor
people gone to college for a long long
time
it's called scholarships and work and go
to a freakin college you can afford the
average in-state tuition in America
right now is twelve thousand dollars you
can make fifteen hundred a month that's
$18,000 delivering pizza at night go to
school during the day and pay your
tuition poor people can go to college I
went to college I was poor I didn't mean
money
I worked my butt off forty to sixty
hours a week while I was in school
people in the neighborhood I grew up in
I mean we didn't know what privilege was
so maybe we were privileged there's no
privilege here only privilege I had was
growing up with people know how to work
hard
the only privilege I had there's no
existential privilege for people that
come out of our neighborhood like I grew
up in no we just had to go cut it out
and you go cut it out but the problem is
that people are making these decisions
like this and there's no one telling
them no no one there's no boundaries on
this at all
and people are goob man you know and if
you didn't grow up in a family that was
educated if you're the first in your
neighborhood to get a college degree the
first on your street nobody on your
street got a college degree because you
grew up in a neighborhood like that like
I did there 15 kids in my neighborhood I
think three of us got four-year degrees
none of our parents had four-year
degrees hardly and so nobody knew how to
tell us how to go to college and if
nobody knows how to tell you how to go
to college you know what you do
but stuff like pay four times too much
for a degree and going debt to do it
that's what you do if you're nobody
knows how to tell you how to do it and
and in the process you and either
taxpayers are ensuring these loans 1.6
trillion dollars the default rate goes
up every day don't talk to me about
forgiving student loans don't talk to me
about free college until you stop making
these stupid butt loans Congress